sometimes it feels like life
is a series of
okay that's getting really annoying as I
was saying sometimes it feels like that
should do it so
okay Microsoft we get it you want us to
update to Windows 10 so badly you've set
a deadline come July 29th Windows 10
will no longer be a free upgrade to
Windows 7 and 8.1 users after that it
will cost you 119 dollars to upgrade to
Windows Home and 199 to Windows Pro and
guess what yup even if you're already a
Windows 10 user you've got another
update headed your way on August 2nd so
should you install all these updates
Windows 10 is a huge step up from the
confusing mess that is Windows 8 or 8.1
it brings back the Start menu and
navigating around is far more like
Windows 7 plus the new keyboard and
mouse tricks are great there's also
Cortana the handy built-in personal
assistant that you can type or talk to
Kanye West is married to Kim Kardashian
the new edge browser is also faster and
more power efficient than Internet
Explorer does that mean everything's
going to work perfectly for you look
I've upgraded two laptops this week and
they've been perfectly fine but I've
also heard some real horror stories
here's what you can do to minimize the
possible pain before anything backup
everything on your system - a hard drive
or a cloud service offered by Google or
Microsoft if you rely on special
software check with the maker to make
sure it's still compatible with Windows
10 if something goes horribly wrong
microsoft offers phone and online
customer support so what's this new new
Windows Update about I've been testing
the anniversary update and it's got some
cool though not game-changing tricks the
edge browser is more stable and finally
supports extensions like this one from
LastPass that will autofill your
passwords Cortana now also works on the
lock screen is it going to rain tomorrow
no it's unlikely but a lot of these
updates are for new PCs like the surface
pro there are new stylus tricks like
this new sketch pad app and these sticky
notes an update allows Windows hello
facial recognition to work in the store
with third-party apps with just a
software update you can get great new
features and your computer can feel
brand new it can also break everything I
believe Windows 10 is worth the leap of
faith especially while it's free it's
modern it's fast and it will rid you of
oh come on